cette exposition s'appelle feuille songe
parce que comme il s'agit de son jardin
secret
sur feuilles donc il y a pas de toile il
y a pas d'autres supports on a fait un
jeu de mots entre quelque chose qu'on
connaît très bien dans notre culture
réunionnaise et ces fameux supports sur
lesquels délirait c'était vraiment son
monde à part son monde intérieur qui est
Jean-Philippe rivière alors déjà c'est
mon papa un journaliste
engagé donc une vie assez remplie
entre quelqu'un qui adore les lettres la
littérature la poésie un engagement pour
on sent qu'il y a une sensibilité qui
est marquée par des inégalités les
années fin des années 60-70 il savait
absolument
au fond rétablir une certaine justice
parce que il a été il nous a été enlevé
trop tôt j'ai voulu que notre fille
tienne bras cette exposition c'était une
sorte de transmission d'héritage
[Musique]
il faut se rappeler de cette réunion pas
si vieille que ça finalement mais de
tout cet engagement de meeting
d'élections
d'événements passionnés de clash parce
qu'il y en a eu et tout simplement ben
journaliste qui dans cet engagement
politique il a aussi fait à mon avis du
chemin parce qu'il était pas forcément
le même à la fin de sa vie jeune
trentenaire que ce qu'il avait été la
fougue d'un jeune 68 heures revenant au
pays
[Musique]
j'ai fait un peu la connaissance avec
tout ça parce que il meurt moi j'ai 5
ans mais entre ma maman et puis d'autres
qui ont été témoins donc ça a permis
quand même de reconstituer tout un
parcours
[Musique]
les noirs sont assez beaux on sent que
ça n'a jamais été vraiment montré donc
on les montre enfin et on peut faire un
parallèle intéressant entre la noirceur
la précision qu'on trouve sur ce mot
écrit et sur ces dessins dans certains
sont assez
minutieux délicat
assez précis
[Musique]
ça me touche
et à la fois j'espère vraiment que pour
le patrimoine réunionnais des gens qui
n'ont pas connu cette période des tout
jeune et ben ce dessin cette précision
si regardez étrange et tout ça va aussi
les
interpeller les toucher également
[Musique]